[Music]
in easy money news submitted by Waffle
House Oh miss that place all the time
me too is it that good it was all right
it's nasty but it holds a place in my
heart me too and the waffle is a dollar
I got a place like that too so it's a
dirty truck stop it was costing we had
it I got three mm were supposed to have
it 24 hours dirty truck stop Oh in a
Florida
Bo Ryan a man agreed to a $100,000 bet
to stay in total isolation in darkness
for 30 days holy [ __ ]
abso-fucking-lutely not cannot do it I
will lose my mind and I'd kill myself I
would without any visual stimulant but
you get $100,000 400,000 go crazy you
can actually go crazy from that yeah can
you go yeah that's why we're not even
allowed to keep prisoners in their
solitary for very long yeah they need
like an hour of sunlight a day or
something also like in the dark
bleep pitch darkness not even like there
cannot be a single light no phone gets
the anything yet they like pretty much
them ask you something well there is a
light at the end of the tunnel there is
a light at the end of the tunnel and
it's called $100,000 if you can make
that's it though 30 days if you can make
it would you do it
I don't I think you of all people can't
do it I've been in the dark for 30 days
straight like complete with all of us
and I do that just floating in the dark
I like I like it I'll have you gone back
for 30 days though no stimulation only
your thoughts but I know I'm gonna get a
hundred thousand and thirty days I gotta
see this I want to see if you could do
it for at least five days no cuz it's if
I if it was just a challenge and then I
know I'm going back to normal so but
then you don't even know what day it is
no what's bothering you yeah it's okay
cuz I think we all know how much
stimulation you need and I don't know if
you know stimulation yeah you're high
series you don't know how much
imagination I have in his art but you
could be imagining like a [ __ ]
guys can't even do just flow I can and
you're like [ __ ] that was a good week
and then it's like that's five minutes
we ate in the dark I know that was
already scary
yeah and you remember I wasn't scared
you were a little bit scared everyone
freaked I was a little bit scared and
that stimulation to your eating anyway
there's people you can eat for 30 days I
was completely alone
- it's pretty please I'm gonna have to
say I think it's a pretty hard challenge
in an hour I would hyperventilate I'd
[ __ ] faint and I would just first
three minutes oh yeah yeah why did I say
an hour who the [ __ ] do I think I am I
can't even last more than a minute in
the complete darkness and the just float
thing I have to turn on the light the
night light okay if you can do it 30
seconds I'm done
I think they turn off the lights I'm
like normally there are markers at least
there's someone come in okay day one
you're like oh I don't think so
[ __ ] that's why what I did just flow it
feels like 10 minutes even though it's
an hour okay okay so these are two pork
poker players that they even more ease
it yes they had just met and they were
like somehow in the conversation it led
to the question of like you know how
long do you think you can last in
complete darkness complete isolation
zero human interaction and then that's
when so Rory young asked rich I'll a lot
T and so that's when rich was like 30
days and then worried was like what the
[ __ ] thirty days I was maximum 30 days
is like how long he could last
so then what they ended up doing is that
they both deposited $100,000 of their
own money in an escrow account agreeing
to pay the other side if they would like
to be respected right that's so cool
that's some hardcore [ __ ] right there
I want money what I'm doing is they
rented out an air B&B in Henderson lots
of the bad guys yeah and Nevada so it's
like mirror Vegas yeah and then they got
this everybody they got people to go in
like a contractor like it out in
blackout spent more money on a shoot the
natural about 10,000 I'll get in there
man that's like nothing to them yeah so
then the oxygen they also got lawyers to
drop contracts why
[ __ ] legit and then there's dope they
installed a whole bunch of security
cameras that some of them would do
24-hour private livestream so the family
can check in on him and he can talk he
can talk to people you just can't see or
like touch anyone okay okay now I don't
think it's as hard yeah it's hard but
talking to people helps out a lot hell
yeah so you can is it because I would
call all you guys out up and then we
would split it so you could have
conversation so it's just one way like
hey I'm okay good question is if it's
just the one way like they're watching
you that's harder there's somebody told
me I had to do think it might be that
but if it's a full-on conversation time
can go by maybe not because so let me
tell you the rest of it so then um they
also had food drop-offs
so he was able to order whatever food he
wanted and have as much food as you
wanted he also had certain amenities
that they agree they came to an
agreement for him to have in this master
bathroom because it's it was one tiny
room it literally was small so first of
all this is Rory and rich Rory would
really look like they would make her
which one was doing it he was the one I
was in complete isolation he already
looks like he lives in darkness yeah so
this is what it looked like like these
security cameras they're completely
pitch black later that like night vision
yeah and then so here's my photo and so
um I'm gonna need a separate room so I
could just jack off when I was just all
in one room and so they also had he had
fall in the bathroom yeah all in the
bathroom so they put a bed on the floor
and then he had that bathtub and then he
had he had a well he does have this like
private toilet so I guess he could close
the door oh yeah thank God he has a
jacket is that the feel around it [ __ ]
yeah so then oh here's another photo he
also had a mini fridge that they removed
the light so that was like my thing so
he just has to feel around for food yeah
so he arrived two days earlier than the
vet started from the Bahamas so you
could familiarize himself he arranged
the whole room like how he wanted it to
arise everything he was saying that the
first few days he was like crawling but
then eventually he got comfortable and
he was like yeah I bought my head up
quite a lot but then he would use the
bathtub to do those uh push-ups but like
where you go down like below
he called it something that push it it
guys something like that um and then he
had like a resistance man whatever like
he exercised just working out fine being
so occupied his time yeah he get his
wigglies out and then uh so he was
saying that it's something that Rory
didn't know about him before placing
that bed is that for the last six years
he had been really into meditation and
like he actually spent some time in like
a silent what is the thing that the
monks do the monastery monastery but the
thing they use that where they don't
speak at all for like along I forgot
it's I don't know I don't know the term
but it's a quiet pack yeah but you do
that for like I did like all you do for
a week or whatever yeah he do it for
like a whole month or something that so
then like he's been like you was
prepared yeah for this because so then
when I'm not happening was it tricked
them yeah rich would go and check up on
his his mental health and he they also
did drug test like they they made him
submit urine like oh so you can't take
drugs
thank you was like I wonder people went
in with like night vision goggles to
administer all this [ __ ]
I need not truck it was because it was
supposed to be zero interaction so it
was maybe like adored thing or something
so then it was already around the twenty
so on the 20th day they finally came to
an agreement for a buyout because rich
was like oh no now retro re it was like
oh [ __ ] he's like fully in this he's
having no problems
he's like [ __ ] I'm gonna lose $100,000
let me try to cut my losses so he ended
up offering hey offering him a prorated
part of the bet so it turned out to be
sixty two thousand four hundred dollars
this poker player trick you no wonder
they had like escrow contracts they just
nah sneak each other are not in a bad
way now I would have said no dude I'm
fine I want the hundred grand hundred
Sheldon no he was gonna win it
initially he offered him $25,000 and the
bet on the spot he was like nope after
20 days yeah no that's why it was like
the 14th day or something cuz he was
like oh [ __ ] he's gonna finish yeah he's
gonna do it might not even know it's
been 30 20 days I would trick on my bike
dude you've only been in it for three
days man like it's like like what two
weeks and he goes dude how's that six
hours doing what do you mean we mean a
bug and took like 20 naps already yes
and three hours as a timer in there or
like no timer but they did mention that
Rory thinks that rich kind of he had
like an upper hand because there were
there was like this landscaping project
nearby so he could hear like some motor
you think that gives you a marker of
time is a huge advantage yeah yeah
doesn't drive you crazy that helped him
a lot but he did say rich said that he
did hallucinate a lot when he was there
but then in the beginning he was really
scared and like he just had to remember
to like change his perspective of his
thought because of the whole meditating
and everything that he was able to
remove the fear from the hallucinations
and just enjoy it and have fun with his
hallucination so that one point he said
that there was that there was this like
all these like white bubbles started
showing up and he was like [ __ ] it we're
gonna have a bubble party and then like
this other time we're like the roof
opened and it was like the Stars there
oh my god I was excited
what the [ __ ] is wrong with this guy I
think about life up high
yeah that's true and then another point
that rain yeah like a train was there
and he was just like bucket we're having
fun with this train but that's dope
so by letting his mind go kind of he
didn't lose his mind yes he entertained
himself yeah but you know these have to
jack off a lot dude
he said that coming out of this
experience I haven't made him yeah he
wants to do another you just crazier bet
or it's like no bed no nice amenities
like I'm down to do it even longer and
like all this [ __ ] like he's just like
[ __ ] him take my legs I'm gonna lose his
mind laughs yeah but he says like he
came out of that like way like a way
calmer person and within 36 hours of
getting out out of that room he was
playing a poker in a poker tournament at
the Bellagio like he was just like right
back into his normal world but they had
to give him Eclipse glasses coming out
oh because it's too bright anything like
really dimly lit [ __ ] yeah it's pretty
intense
that's [ __ ] well poker players have
some crazy mental endurance though it's
pretty nuts
[Music]